the only thing that can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic well welcome everybody out
there and watching this live or perhaps
watching it recorded
I am Brian Keating and I'm the Associate
Director of the arthur c-- clark center
for human imagination at the university
of california san diego and today also a
physics professor and today i'm
delighted to be joined with james gates
who is a professor at brown university
he is the director is a brown
theoretical physics center director and
Brown University was my alma mater where
I got my PhD oh so many years ago and
remember with great fondness and I only
wish that he had been there when I was
there maybe I would have had a different
career and maybe could have advanced to
experimental physics in my absence but
but today we're here to talk with
professor gates about his new book which
is called proving Einstein right and
some aspects of the continual quest that
physicists such as Einstein and all the
way up through lectures on gravitation
by by Fineman and others leading up to
Jim and Stephen Hawking have really been
compelled to understand what is the
nature of gravity and how enticing and
how fascinating
gravity is and I wonder given all the
contributions you've made in physics
especially in supersymmetry which is
coming in on some ways really sprang
from your brain in the 1970s while you
were writing the first degree on that
PhD thesis on that at MIT and then had
so much influence on physics and in some
sense even though you're the father
sometimes I joke you're kind of denying
paternity in some sense you know that
you're you're maybe not as comfortable
some of the claims made about
supersymmetry so I hope to get into all
this we'll try to keep it general so
people get interested and get to know
Jim's work if they don't already know it
already and so first I want to welcome
you back to San Diego well thank you
Brian this is my first time on your
campus I've been here San Diego before
but never here at UCSD yeah let me
correct you
one thing I think important for anyone
who be interested in proving Einstein
right - no I have a co-author yes she is
a novelist she has written novels for 30
years and she is extraordinary as a
writer so the thing that is kind of
weird about our book is what happens
when a theoretical physicist bumps until
now because you know as a theoretical
physicist you know we're not expected to
be great writers and novelists are not
expected to know about physics so the
book really is something that could only
be done in an team and we're quite proud
of what we read yeah I was delighted to
be asked to see and look at some of the
early you know first first edition of
the book over the summer last summer and
was really gripped by as I said and
discussing it with with you and with
Kathy or co-authors just wonderful
writer and so energetic about the
physics topics that are covered for a
non-expert I was blown away but I said
it reads like a novel and I actually
didn't know she was a novelist when I
said that and I said it's truly a
page-turner so congratulations on that
and I'm really excited about that and I
want to just start right there so okay
so the title so proving Einstein right
so normally when I talk to people in the
press especially after different events
that have transpired in my career I've
become reluctant when people ask me what
do you hope to discover with your
experiment the Simon's Observatory or by
Sol or whatever what do you hope to
discover and you can say well you know
jobs are as experimentalist is really to
prove people wrong not to prove them
right
and and and maybe it's different in
theoretical physics but what is the
origin of that title what does it mean
to you and to Kathy well first of all
Kathy Pelletier and I respect highly the
work of people who actually go out and
look and talk to nature theorists don't
actually do that into the large degree
we exist in this kind of duality between
mathematics and reality and we're always
in tension trying to find a human way to
tell a story and so Kathy and I and
writing this book we although we chose
the title proving Einstein right for the
reader who is actually carefully
watching what we're doing we also try to
get the reader tons
and that science doesn't prove things
right it proves things wrong and in fact
one of the things that I quote of ice
time which is a real favorite of mine is
I'm gonna paraphrase he basically says
that the life of a theorist is not to be
in deed and the reason is because nature
is a very strict taskmaster mmm-hmm and
she never says you're right that most
she will give you is a maybe maybe and
even then he conjectured that at some
point maybe all theories what we found
to be wrong so it's it's a very
interesting relation I know the public
thinks that science is about things
being right but you can't prove things
right right yeah and and in fact you
know I think a friend of ours mutual
friend Alex Filippenko at UC Berkeley
said something to the effect and maybe
he's quoting in somebody else's name you
know an experimentalist only needs to be
wrong once in his or her career to have
his/her her career terminated that a
theorist only has to be right once in
his or her life to make a career and no
stakes are high and I think you know
Einstein had many you know blunders and
mistakes and of course our other mutual
friend Mario Livio wrote a book about
not only including limited to Einstein
but many other famous physicists and and
and and biologists etc that made you
know blunderers quote unquote that
sometimes turned out to be you know
prescient and sometimes turned out to be
not so and I always found it interesting
that you know Einstein's predictions
that lead up to this book and the book
spans a over a decade of time yes 1911
to 1922 and it's a very loving portrait
and you get into the minds you get into
the psychology of these astronomers
these finance years these travel agents
it's just unbelievable how how were you
able to you know I mean you're
previously known for running very
technical books on supersymmetry and
things like that or your other passions
how was it to both have to carry the
water so to speak for the for the
physics meat and potatoes but also to
get into the psychological and character
studies that you did sure let me first
of all again
my co-author it turns out although Kathy
predominantly has worked in fiction and
writing novels she has an amazing
ability as a detective or as a
researcher and so she was able to
actually for example contact descendants
of the characters that we were writing
about so we had access to writings that
the characters were actually telling
their families at the time they were
doing these things right and even later
so all praise the catch I remember
getting an email from her and was
already interrupted as she was asking
what's the maximum duration of any clip
and I'm like sure Jim it's not gonna
answer like if you know it was very it
was very journalistic almost that she
was getting into it so in such great
they that's exactly right in fact Kathy
paid me a great compliment recently we
were being interviewed and she said that
I have in some such changed her as a
writer hmm and part of that she you know
her comment was as a novelist
she has absolute control when she says a
character has a blue shirt on certain
day they character has a blue shirt and
on day but she said she found and
working in this realm where reality is
fixed she found out the chief
she had this deep passion for accuracy
and of course that's what journalists
want but that's also of course how we
make our living it is accuracy that we
deliver to the world because that
accuracy is what undergirds our
technology which allows us to provide
great apps to humanitarian benefits
mm-hmm when you think about this great
character Einstein I mean no single
physicist I remember seeing a picture of
Time magazine I think the week after he
passed away in the 5055 versus died in
1955 yeah do you remember when he died
do you remember I don't and it's
interesting because my interest in
science has actually preceded his death
around 1953 or 54 I first got interested
in science but I don't remember hearing
about Einstein until like 1957 so after
he died so I was not aware of his death
I remember the covers depicted you know
planet Earth I seen from space with a
giant sign that said in Stein lived here
all remember that cover so so much
larger than life as you know the beer
the mustache rather and the pipe and the
violin and the bicycle these things that
that
you know really fascinated him and there
are similarities I would say between the
two of you and that you have many
hobbies you know many interest outside
do you find that you know these these
different interests that you've had
throughout your career whether it be or
you know in the professional level as a
bowler essentially at MIT and Caltech
when you're a postdoc or you know the
interest that you had in the space
program and actually trying to qualify
as an astronaut do these things give you
mere kind of a psychological respite
from the rigors of being a theoretical
physicist where they feed a different
part of your spirit they feed a
different part of my spirit quite
frankly and the things that you you're
very kind in your praise but most of the
things you're talking about are deep in
my past they're not things that
potentially going to return to the realm
of reality but I have all although I
have a deep passionate love for science
which started when I was four years old
I also understood about the personality
that I am that I wanted to do lots of
things in fact that for me the idea
would have been to create maybe ten
clones and that each one of them do a
different thing because I had that many
things I wanted to do so what I've been
able to do in my career is build
multiple careers on the basis of this
first one which is a deep passionate
love for physics and trying to get it
right at the mathematical physics
interface you don't want me in your lab
because I will destroy your equipment we
went in before and of course it's
smouldering right now that's right so
I've always told people that that's
somehow something that's bad as a
skillset that I do not possess and I
know that I learned that when I was a
student at MIT and so I have very great
admiration and appreciation for what it
is
that people who go and observe nature do
in our discipline I often tell people
physics is not a faith-based
organization and the reason it's not is
because we are in conversation with
nature with our observations and with
our experiments and without that physics
becomes like a religion I want to come
back to that in a little bit hopefully I
won't forget but I do want to touch upon
the one last kind of commonality and
difference between you and many
physicists that you do share in common
and
you mention it during an informal talk
you give so kindly to my group earlier
today and that was the aspect of physics
as culture the physics should not be
divorced from a culture thought as a
separate entity from a culture and yet
you know most people would say there's
no way some stem geek your nerd that he
or she is part of like a culture that's
art that's you know paint that's that's
music what are you how do you feel about
about the intern you know the interface
between physics as a as a branch of
culture within us or well I as I read
well I read first of all I refer to
Albert Einstein as my hero Maximus he is
my maximum scientific hero in my life
and it is clear if you look at his life
that he understood that although he had
made these enormous contributions to our
understanding the structure of nature it
was within the context of a cultural
matrix and he was pretty clear about
that and so if you for example one of
the quotes that was of his which is a
favorite of mine is he says and I'm
paraphrasing I'll never get it exactly
right but it essentially says that at
their highest levels art and science
coalesce and plasticity aesthetics and
form so he understands that physics as
the kind of physics that he was engaged
in is in fact an how a product of
culture in the same way that I and by
the way do you know what what he would
have done if he wasn't a physicist I
think I had known I know it wasn't you
know Tour de France competitor but no he
said he'd be a violinist and so he
understood this to me it's more than an
ephemeral connection as I've experienced
creativity in my micro life I've
concluded that there's only there's a
single source of creativity in human
consciousness and that this single
source can be manifest in different ways
whether it be arts whether it be science
whether it be mathematics but that this
this essential thing that allows us to
be creative it looks like it's pretty
much the saint from all the things that
I have read about and so it is not
perhaps surprising that when you look at
our greatest scientists they all seem to
have this message about
science is actually part of culture and
one way by the way that I think that
that's true is because of the way
science has created
unlike lots of music and among my
musical likes is classical music so you
know I liked abuse II I liked
rimsky-korsakov I liked Greek like
little ain I found out today yes well
that's a whole different axis right but
the point of bravery of bringing this up
is if you look at classical music and if
your aficionado of classical music you
can ask yourself well I like all these
things why were the people who created
them how did they create these different
forms and part of that we know the
answer to is because often parts of
classical music's are drawn from folk
music which means that it's arising from
the cultural matrix in which the
individuals themselves exist instead so
if that's going on with music I have a
very strong suspicion that it goes on
actually with all of stem that at the
boundary where we're trying to create
new knowledge it is that irrational
creativity the same thing that powers
the creation of music and art literature
it's that irrational and rationality the
illogical nature that drives how you
make advance what Einstein made one
quote that puzzled me for decades which
was imagination is more important than
knowledge
yeah I always said I don't want my
surgeon to say that
and so that puzzled me for decades I
first learned about Albert Einstein when
I was 16 years old yes when I was first
introduced as special relativity I
thought was one of the most amazing
things that human mind could recreate
and then I came across the statement
imagination is more important than
knowledge and I was like how can that
possibly be because for me at that age
imagination was about Marvel comic book
superheroes is about science fiction it
was about the imagination just being a
space where I could creatively engineer
worlds within my ears that's why I
thought about imagination but for him
too
say that that is more important than
knowledge like special relativity like
Newton's law which are things that often
ly provide an enormous benefit for our
species how could he say that was my
question
right and so I decade later I think I
concluded he was right and I think it
works like this knowledge is like a ball
of ball of finite size at any given
point in time we humans have a finite
amount of knowledge and if you go if you
wait a decade or so we have more so the
question is how does this ball grow and
the answer as far as I can tell and have
experience and watch other scientists
work is that we actually make up the new
Answers and where does that come from
it comes from our imagination yeah and
if that's the case then I believe that
one can understand how the ill rational
and the illogical parts of us that are
embedded in our cultural matrix are
contributing to the achievement and
growth of science and so interesting you
mentioned that because you know the
center that I'm associate director of is
called the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination and the title of this
podcast that we call that is the podcast
of the center is called into the
impossible and it's based on a quote by
sir arthur c clarke which said the only
way to determine what's possible is to
go beyond into the impossible and that's
kind of this expanding sphere of
knowledge and and what is it expanding
into not the void but really into
ignorance or perhaps into the impossible
which we don't understand yeah I like to
think of it as a standing in for
darkness because it's shedding light for
the human mind in such a way that we as
a species at least in principle have a
shot of living more bountiful lives so
to me that's what the expansion is about
so getting back to the book proving
Einstein right that you wrote with with
Cathy pellet hearing this this story is
really a human drama and it's spanning
continents and it's spanning you know
world war two and one free oh sorry
world war one rather sorry I meant
pre-world War to World War one and
across the globe and it was a dangerous
time and it was
time of ideologies and and passions and
stereotypes and prejudices against this
type of physics I always think you know
I said I had one thing going for him in
this course to you know maybe prove his
theory of general relativity right which
is that he had the work of Newton that
he was standing on whose shoulders he
was standing and they knew he knew that
they were something on about mercury and
that that's a little bit different than
say the state of affairs when we find
ourselves today as physicists we we can
make a theory but oftentimes we can't I
shouldn't say we I should say you
theorist in your in your fellow
theorists you guys can predict theory
but you don't often have a predict a
retro diction against which to compare
in other words he had this advanced the
perihelion of mercury so they knew
something was deeply wrong with with
Newtonian theory alone for hundreds of
years perhaps absolutely and so how is
it to work on this expansion into the
impossible as we were thinking what
would it have been like for him you know
as compared to someone like you and and
and in the modern era where we don't
really have testable you know kind of
retro addictions against which we can
compare supersymmetric procedures well
first of all we do actually have for
some very mild retro diction because you
know in a sense that you can't is a
theorist you can't write something that
would be in conflict with the standard
model because of your friends would
laugh at you immediately right so in
that sense we need like I say but the
you're right the retro dictions are less
sharply defined now than perhaps at any
point in the history of the field and
that leaves that leaves room for lots of
people to exercise their imagination and
their creativity to try to imagine the
way the world works and I on the other
hand although you mentioned I was one of
the early adopters first adopters of the
idea of supersymmetry
I'm actually an extraordinarily
conservative physicist yes and so
although I will I think it's valuable to
explore an idea like supersymmetry and I
think even though why it's valuable
which is not what most of my colleagues
believe I think that we run a danger of
trying to
trying to create scenarios where there
are almost no retro addictions that
confined our imagination as I said it's
that conversation that stops us from
being a faith-based operation right yeah
so make it back to that so mmm I've hurt
you and I've talked actually about this
notion of what constitutes you know good
physics and and this is a matter of
philosophy and taste and but it comes
down to oftentimes comes down to Karl
Popper it was a logician a theater
philosopher who came up with his famous
demarcation kind of hypothesis which
said you can tell if something is
scientific if it can be falsified and in
many cases you know so Einstein's theory
of general relativity which is a large
portion of the subject of your book
proving Einstein right was known at
least could explain it although there
were some errors of factors of 2 in the
in the mercury calculate the factor of 2
between and and and it could have easily
been proven wrong and and in fact many
people had deep suspicions even decades
and you mentioned this in the book you
guys point this there were deep
suspicions if it were correct really
even until after the 1922 in 1920 sorry
1919 solar eclipse so we were
celebrating the centennial of the famous
Eclipse that sort of solidified
Einstein's reputation for all time but
but but even up until that time it
wasn't clear that that there was any
room necessarily for falsifiability of
that and and I think people could say
well there could have been some other
theory that could have shamed the
advance of the perihelion of mercury and
so you couldn't really prove it wrong so
is it the case that you see that
Einstein was kind of in a no-win
situation like he famously said well
what if your what if the expedition had
been you know I've proven you wrong and
he said I would have felt sorry for the
good lord because the equations are
correct I don't believe that he was
really that confident to you I do you do
I do mm-hmm because you know we have to
reflect a little bit on his trajectory
so starting at 15 he in his mind begins
to construct
the philosophical basis for special
relativity you add with a very simple
question was the what would the universe
look like if I was riding on a beam of
light right so he starts from this
philosophical basis with his earliest
work and it turns out to be an enormous
triumph it runs the table in the
language of some poker games right and
so given that he had had such success
and then the next problem comes along
how does he make his 1905 success
consistent with the law of gravity which
is what Lisa's 1915 work but as you
mentioned he gets it wrong in 1911 I
mean he just totally blows it in 1911
but when he finally gets to the right
answer and is able to show the
procession the prevailing of mercury
comes from his mathematics the thing
that he also said there were three tests
that if any one of them failed the
theory failed one of them was precession
pame mercury but he knew that beforehand
he just had to get to it the seconds in
the hall and there isn't a whole sort of
the second one of course being the
deflection of starlight by this by stars
like the Sun and the third one which you
well know because you are the
accomplished - well this is the third
one was a gravitational Doppler which
didn't get settled for decades after his
even after his death and so if you
actually look at what happened in terms
of the history he says all three have to
be past one of them passes immediately
one of them provisionally gets a fast in
1919 and then in 1922 gets a more
rousing man and the third one doesn't
get a pass until the sixties or
seventies and so what happened well we
clearly did not follow his standard on
proving him right and that's another
reason why we like to use that title
because if as you said in the book we
actually discuss that his statement of
three tests is not satisfied until over
twenty years after his death yes
right and so that was the title is not
to be taken literally it's sort of a
metaphorical title that we want the
reader to come back to as they have read
the text because when most readers
because they say oh of course I know
what that means
hmm after they've read the text we want
them to reflect do you really know what
he meant right and what does history say
about what happened exactly
so getting to the faith-based arguments
that we started to touch upon a few
minutes back you know there's sort of a
culture war going on and physics today
and it revolves around the question of
the reality of multiple universes and
maybe you can say a little bit about the
the origin of such things within the
context of string theory and
supersymmetry I'll just say in the
context of the experimental astrophysics
foreground that I study the context
supposes that if in a period of
exponential inflation occurred at the
earliest moments in the universe perhaps
a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth after a second after the Big
Bang that the universe would unavoidably
be accompanied by a concomitant host of
many other universes and this this when
when it was discovered that there are
certain predictions of string theory
which in some sense could be interpreted
as also providing motivation for multi
verses which maybe you can expound a
little bit upon that that you now have
people speaking about their belief in
the multiverse and you know you've
spoken about this in the past but I
wonder if you could first to
recapitulate work what is the motivation
from just a purely physics not a
philosophy or theology stand for the
multiverse sure so many years ago I was
a participant in the television
production of the elegant universe or
just even I'm sorry where Brian Greene
was the principal host but Steven
Weinberg is in it and so is Shelley
glass shell and Shelley
points out something very interesting in
that that presentation and it's a
problem in fact that bird dogs string
theory to this day essentially I'm gonna
change the language of Shelley so work
but essentially what Shelley points out
not with such fidelity is that the
mathematics of string theory that has
been broadly accepted by many many
theorists has this philosophical hole in
it and the philosophical hold is if you
take strength theory in this simple
mathematical formation its describes the
universe that has nine spatial
directions not our three and so you have
to add this extra mathematical widget in
order to get from the nine dimensions of
the math or the three dimensions of our
observation this widget is called
compactification and when string theory
was first studied in the middle 80s
people were pretty sure there there were
some small number of such mathematical
widgets that you could that you could
use but what Shelley was sensitive to
although he didn't state in this terms
was that no one has actually figured out
how many widgets there are and as long
as you don't know how many widgets there
are to achieve this result that brings
the mathematics of string theory down to
be consistent with their with our with
our observations of dimensionality then
you have no way to falsify so he mails
the point precisely and in a way that
most people who are aficionados of
string theory have yet to address it
took me a decade to conclude that he was
right hmm
that it's the counting of the number of
the way I'd like to say it until you can
tell me mathematically how to count the
number of widgets you do not have a
theory that's falsified
now on the other hand string theory does
have incredibly large numbers of these
widgets depending on what variety that
you want to use this khalaby I'll
compactification then there's this non
geometric structures and there's
asymmetrical oral folds the list goes on
and on and one of the amazing thing to
me is that everything years someone figs
out another one of these widgets
taxonomy yeah oh we found another widget
here right and so that that in and of
itself is saying that there's an
incompleteness and so though until you
satisfy that condition you can't falsify
it and that's what we're that's
the essence of Shelly's message so I
think it was right on the other hand I
about several months ago I brought this
issue up with a physicist at Harvard
coming Bafa who is one of the folks who
are working on a part of string theory
there's a part of string they called F
theory and in that there is a fair body
of mathematical evidence that you can
count the widgets if you can extend that
to all possible string theories then
Shelley's objection goes away and it
becomes falsifiable
but even Vava who's the proponent of
something called the swampland which
you've probably heard of us in the
context of eff theory which is really
the the initial well one of the place he
spends a lot of his intellectual energy
even there there is no absolute proof of
the counting and so until that happens
I'm going to be highly so before we wrap
up I do want to think you know years in
the future hopefully not decades and
decades as it took Einstein to get
verified but if you could imagine future
physicists and novelists collaborating
together to write a book called proving
gates right what would it be what would
the contributions be what would you most
like to see you know if you could have
one divine being answer any one question
about the nature and origin of the
universe nor are the properties there of
its entities therein what would it be
and what fascinates you the most that
you can most like to know the answer to
so as you know Brian I have been
pursuing some well some mathematical
approaches that have been described as
avant-garde or eclectic they involve
taking differential equations and then
recasting them in the language of
networks and then studying the
properties of these networks so we call
these networks of dhingra's and this is
something that I've received a fair
amount of criticism and I can what in
the world why are you doing this and the
answer turns out to be because there are
problems in at the basis of string
theory
that I am aware of from when I was a
postdoc at Harvard that no one has ever
solved and so that suggests that if you
have a problem where you know my the
community to which I belong contains
many individuals of which I am in total
awe and admiration of their intellect
just absolutely the case and yet none of
these people have been able to solve
this particular problem I'm describing
that suggest that you need a new tool to
attack the problem and this network
approach was my effort to start to
develop a new kind of tool to attack
this problem so I've referred this
problem there's the white whale in my
life I'm like Ahab chasing this white
whale
through the darkness that the knowledge
expands into right and so if if the good
Lord would suddenly appear before me say
Jim I'll you know you're gonna die but
in order to do that I'll give you an
answer do you still want to ask the
question I would ask the question and
the question would be how do I find the
irreducible representations of
supersymmetry very good well I want to
finish this at this interview with the
question I like to ask people and it
involves a general nature of imagination
and curiosity and I do that with all I
guess that I'm so privileged to
interview such as yourself and it really
involves you know this you know your
first career in some sense going back to
1972 as a student at MIT where you began
your career as an educator and my
question to you is and there's no right
or wrong answer as far as I can tell is
can you teach you know the kind of
creativity that physicists such as
yourself need to employ in their craft
or is it sort of a divine gift that is
you know visited upon some people by
fortunes got goodliness and providence
in some sense or is it just random luck
let me respond by slightly changing your
question Brian by changing to the issue
of genius mm-hmm because I no longer
think about genius the way I did when I
was a
physicists because I've been around very
bright people and I've watched what's
happened and I don't uh well first of
all I don't think you can teach it but
what you can do is to support the
idiosyncratic thinking patterns that
exist in every single individual that's
what makes us different that you can add
an increased possibility or probability
that the India syncretic nature of an
individual's thinking will lead to a
unique innovative answer that's what I
think you can do as a teacher very good
well dr. Jim Gates Ford Foundation
professor thank you for this opportunity
to speak to you and your audience yes
thank you so much for being here with us
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it'll be absolutely
[Music]